amisia 434 fragt bruder kannst du dir
vorstellen ein gemeinsames album mit
fahrt aufzunehmen
amnesia also die überlegung stand schon
mal um rom
aber keine planung weiß ich nicht
erstmal kommt banger rebellion am
dritten fünften manager möchte wissen
wieso hast du eigentlich mit rap
angefangen weil du keine andere
perspektive hat ist oder bald dass dein
hobby ist
ich denke hobbys entstehen aus dem aus
einem persönlichen interesse so wie du
wahrscheinlich sehr gerne rap erst habe
ich auch sehr fanatisch web gehört und
dann irgendwann kam die situation und
die lust einfach selber raus zu
schreiben und so hat sich das entwickelt
mein freund oder wer war das milieu
liebe grüße an milliman fzj easy ich
würde gerne wissen welchen rapper du
eigentlich feiert beziehungsweise gut
findest
ich feiere die leute die auf meinem
album sind
hallo so ich sehe ich jetzt wirklich in
ein video über den machen
also heißt er wirklich so ist wirklich
gutes essen da ist nicht wirklich
fördern
ok also also du bist mein lieblings
drohte lieblingsrapper du bist mein
lieblings rapper und deshalb wollte ich
wissen was hast du vor dem rappen
gemacht und hattest du irgendein ziel
damals oder was wolltest du damals
werden also hand und beinbruch sagt
mutter also der ging gar hast du dir was
tolles einfallen lassen mit deinem video
schöne grüße an dich ich habe vor der wm
ich hab's schule gemacht ich habe
fußball gespielt ich habe gearbeitet
ich habe gelebt weiß nicht keine ahnung
rap hat sich geschnitten mit meiner
jugend deswegen kann ich nicht so viel
gemacht haben weil ich immer schon red
gehört habe rap mitverfolgt habe und
dann auch irgendwann praktiziert habe
und ja irgendjemand also gewisse
menschen steigern sich dann im
sportverein oder in schule und studium
in ausbildung und bei mir was red ich
finde jetzt auch langsam irgendetwas
haben womit du dich in der zukunft
beschäftigt beschäftigen kannst ging gar
andere erdogan hat folgende frage wie
hast du angefangen so zu retten was
haben deine eltern gesagt mit
freundlichen grüßen
die kmw dicker ich habe angefangen wie
ich angefangen habe habe ich gerade
schon habe ich gerade schon erzählt
einfach aus persönlichem interesse weil
ich selber die musik gerne gehört habe
um meinen eltern die waren erst mal
richtig dagegen die haben gesagt mach
lieber deine schule macht ein fußball
vernünftig weil ich auch fußball
gespielt habe dann jahre
aber was soll ich machen so ist das halt
wenn man sagt mach das nicht macht dies
nicht irgendwie bekommt man immer mehr
bock drauf
deswegen habe ich das durchgezogen mit
dem rap und mittlerweile bekommen meine
eltern dass ihr natürlich auch mit wenn
sie die zeitung aufschlagen schon dann
diesen stolz auf mich jetzt wird's
persönlich mit omar k tipp wie müsste
deine traumfrau sein und hasste sie
schon gefunden
ich habe ich hab's wirklich blöde
situation erlebt in meinem leben was
frauen angeht und habe
meine traumfrau vielleicht schon finden
können vielleicht habe ich sie nicht
gehalten
ich weiß nicht aber ich habe meine
traumfrau so als solches nicht an meiner
seite
also ich bin solo nummer ist keine
ahnung mal gucken was mich erwartet
casey was gilt mein name ist er co ich
habe zwei fragen an die ich der erste
wäre wie kam es dazu dass du beim
channel jetzt die zweite habt ihr als
team kollege ein feature in planung ja
dann nein ich danke dir längere will
ihren preis grüße erstmal ergo denke du
meinst jetzt warum ich bei meiner musik
bin nicht beim channel also oder nicht
denke ich das angebot einfach super war
und ich mich sehr gut verstehe ich
weiterhin meine künstlichen freiheiten
habe die ich auch in der vergangenheit
hatte und ich denke ich kann mich auch
noch einem noch größeren publikum
einfach vorstellen
es sieht ja alles ganz gut aus die musik
ist dieselbe es läuft alles prima warum
nicht ich denke das war die antwort zu
deiner frage falls du wirklich wissen
wollte warum schafft in banger channel
laufe dann ist die antwort darauf weil
ich bei meiner musik unterschrieben
haben
die zweite frage ist ob ich mit kollegah
was gemacht habe ich habe mit kollegah
bis dato noch nichts gemacht aber ich
verstehe mich gut mit ihm und ich
respektiere auch seine arbeit und ich
wünsche ihnen weiterhin viel erfolg und
schöne grüße an kollege realismus ist an
deiner meinung über folgende person
interessiert
casey rebell was hältst du von christoph
krachten christoph krachten ist wie der
name schon mit im behalten wirklich eine
kracher person und clixoom ist auf jeden
fall richtig korrekt gibt euch christoph
krachten und
klicks und ich bin den christoph noch am
überreden dass er eine eigene
facebook-seite mit einem gefällt mir
seite macht weil ich denke er könnte in
der kommenden zeit zu einer kult person
werde
hallo elisabeth
danke für dein video warum ich bei
binger musik bin habe ich gerade schon
beantwortet und ob ihr auf meiner
nächsten tour mit dabei sein wird
in einigen städten vielleicht ja aber
das ist dann nichts was geplant ist
sondern weil wir einfach freunde sind
auch gemeinsam miteinander abhängen und
in wenn wir bei wenn er frei hat oder
ich frei habe und auch gegenseitig oft
besuchen und unterstützen deswegen kann
ich schon gut vorkommen dass er in der
einen oder anderen stadt mit dabei sein
wird
aber die tour ist mit summer jam und die
tour heißt auf die linke tour und die so
fängt an am 24 05
ihr kommt vorbei und isabell auch und
martin smolinski willst du mehr party
mensch oder der chillige typ
gute frage nächste spaß ich bin mehr
ich bin so inzwischen den also ich bin
schon party mit aber nicht im club also
club mag ich gar nicht so sehr gehe ich
auch ab und zu aber einfach einen
draufmachen mit freunden vielleicht
irgendwo sich hinsetzen eine kleinigkeit
trinken was unternehmen kartenspiel
miteinander so was gibt mir persönlich
oder irgendwas anderes spielen keine
ahnung was so was gibt mir persönlich
viel mehr wie wenn ich in einen club
gehen wo laute musik ist wo man sich
sowieso nicht verständigen kann tanzen
tue ich auch nicht ich meine muss auch
jeder für sich selber entscheiden ich
bin jetzt eine person die jetzt nicht
einfach so ein klub gehen kann tanzen
kann ich fühle mich zu sehr beobachtet
die leute kennen mich deswegen jeder
muss das für sich selber entscheiden ich
denke ich bin schon ein gestörter mensch
ich mag es zu hause dvd-abend solche
geschichten ja für die 50